[Music]
Awesome. Thank you, Ben. Excited for the
AI education summit. Should be fun. Um,
my name is Logan. I do developer stuff
at DeepMind, and I'm excited to talk
about Gemini stuff. Um, yeah, hopefully
folks know what Gemini is. So, no
introduction needed. Um, I'll talk about
three things really quickly. We'll do
some fun announcement stuff. Um, we'll
talk about sort of recapping a year of
progress in Gemini. And then we'll talk
about what's coming next across the
model side, across the Gemini app side,
and also across uh, of course the
developer platform.
So, the fun stuff which is we announced
a new Gemini model today. Um, so we
haven't officially announced it, but
we'll post live on the tweet,
new Gemini model. Uh, this is hopefully
the final update to 2.5 Pro. I think
folks have given us tons of feedback um
about the changes and I think my slide
has an animation which is hiding all the
stuff. But Gemini 2.5 Pro is awesome.
Um, it's it's super powerful. Uh, bunch
of increases across, you know,
benchmarks people care about. It's soda
on ADER and um it's soda on HLE and some
other benchmarks. Um I think it closes
the gap on a bunch of the stuff that
folks gave us feedback on from the
previous versions of the model. Um so
hopefully it has great performance
across the board. It also um I I think
is like sort of setting the stage for
the future of Gemini. I think 2.5 Pro
for us internally and I think in the
perception from the developer ecosystem
was the turning point which was super
exciting. Um, so it's awesome to see the
momentum. We've got a bunch of other
great models coming as well. Um, so 2.5
Pro, hopefully the final version. Send
us feedback if things don't work. Uh,
and we'll we'll continue to push the
rock up the hill. Um, you can go to
ai.dev if you want to try it out. It's
also available in the Gemini app and all
that other stuff. Um, and if you need
anything, email us and we'll make it
happen. All right, new model launched.
Let's talk about a year of Gemini
progress. I think this has been the
craziest thing. So, I don't know if
folks tuned in to to Google IO, but um
Sundar showed this slide on stage, which
I think was a uh was a great reminder
for me of just how much like it feels
like 10 years of of Gemini stuff packed
into the last uh 12 months, which has
been awesome. Um and it's it's actually
interesting to see as well, just to sort
of opine on one of the points, like all
of these different research bets across
Deep Mind coming together to like build
this incredible mainline Gemini model.
And I think this is actually like I have
a conversation with people all the time
about like what is what's the Demine
strategy? What's the advantage for us
building models all that good stuff and
I think the interesting thing to me is
just this breath of research happening
across like science and Gemini and all
these other areas like robotics and
things like that. Um and all that
actually ends up upstreaming into the
mainline models which is super exciting.
Um so you see like the you know alpha
proof and alpha geometry and a bunch of
stuff that we did on uh in with custom
models in those areas actually improving
the performance of our models uh for
those domains and uh Jack will talk
about that in a little bit which I'm
super excited about. Um the other thing
is just like not just the pace of
innovation but the pace of adoption. Um
so I think uh Sunar also showed this
slide which was a 50x increase in the
amount of AI inference that's being
processed uh through Google servers from
one year ago to um last month and I
think that is it is just remarkable to
see the amount of increase in demand for
um for Gemini models and for also from
the external developer ecosystem. So
it's been it's been wonderful to see
that happen.
I think the other question and I think
this is like talked about a little bit
which is uh sort of what what got us to
this point. I think one of the critical
pieces and like it's you know not super
fun uh but is worth thinking about uh
for folks who are building companies
here uh is like an organizational thing
truthfully like I think you bring
together Google historically had lots of
different teams doing lots of different
AI research um and in late 2023 early
2023 uh Google brought a bunch of those
teams together um and sort of charted
this new direction for the DeepMind team
to not only just like do theoretical
foundational research but also to like
build models and deliver them to the
rest of Google and also the external
world. Um and then we took the second
step of that journey later uh earlier
this year um which was actually bringing
the product teams into DeepMind. So now
DeepMind creates the models, does the
research um but then also builds
products and delivers delivers those to
the world. And we have the Gemini app
which is our consumer product and then
we have the developer side of that with
the Gemini API. Um and this has been
like personally for me super fun to get
to collaborate with our research team
and like help actually be on the
frontier with them um and bring new
models and capabilities to the world. I
think this is like the collaboration
that works uh works incredibly well.
Yeah. And we ship lots of stuff. I think
this is the this is the most fun part um
is there's so much stuff so much
innovation happening inside of Google.
It's it's incredible to get to bring
that to the world and bring that to
developers and I think we're actually
very early in that journey and as we'll
we'll see in a couple of minutes. Um
so in summary the formula is simple.
bring the best people together, find
infra advantages, and ship.
I don't know if folks have played around
with VO or not, but it's also been just
incredible to see the reception to VO.
It's, uh, burning all the TPUs down, uh,
which has been incredible to see, lots
of demand, uh, lots of interest on the
VO front. Um, so hopefully folks get a
chance to play around. It's available in
the Gemini app right now. Um, all right.
So, let's talk about what next. This is
the fun stuff. So, I think the the sort
of Gemini app piece is interesting just
because people talk about it a lot and
it's um it's a fun product and it's cool
to think about. Um and also sort of I
think for folks building stuff, it's
interesting to hear like what our
strategy is from the app perspective. Um
but the Gemini app is trying to be this
universal assistant. I think what that
means in practice is if you um I'm sure
people don't think about this all the
time, but I think a lot about like what
Google's products do and and sort of how
we show up in the world. And one of the
interesting observations I had was that
if you think about what what was the
thing that like brought people
individuals through all of Google's
products historically like the thing
that comes to mind is like like your
Google account I guess which like did
wasn't like super stateful. You would
sort of sign into lots of different
Google products with your Google account
but that didn't really do anything um
other than just like get you signed into
that individual product. I think now
we're seeing with Gemini that it's
actually this thread that unifies all of
Google. And I think the future for
Google is going to look a lot like
Gemini is this sort of, you know, thread
that brings all of our stuff together.
Um, which is really interesting. And
then hitting on all the trends which I'm
sure folks are also excited about
building. I think the one that I'm most
excited about is proactivity. I think
most AI products today are still very
like you have to go and do all the work
as the user. And I think this proactive
uh next step of um AI systems and models
coming into play is going to be is going
to be awesome to see.
Yeah, and the team is moving super fast.
If you have complaints, please do not
tag me on Twitter. Please tag Josh. Um,
he will make it happen. Josh is
incredible. The Gemini app team is
amazing. Um, he's he's pushing the team
uh super hard. So, it's incredible to
see all the progress. Uh, but he is the
person who can make stuff happen on the
Gemini app, not me. So, please check
him. Um, from a model perspective, like
again, there's there's so much. Uh when
Gemini was originally created, it was
built to be a a single multimodal uh
model to do audio, image, video, etc.
We've made a lot of progress on that. At
IO this year, we announced um native
audio capabilities in Gemini. There's
TTS. There's audio uh you can talk to
the model. It sounds it sounds super
natural, which is awesome. It's powering
the Astro experience. It's powering
Gemini Live. Um so I think we're going
to get towards that omnimal model, which
is awesome. We have VO, which is soda
across a bunch of stuff. So hopefully
we'll get video into the mainline Gemini
model. Um, if folks saw some of our
early experiments with diffusion, which
means you can get like crazy levels of
tokens per second. Um, really
interesting. That's like definitely a
research exploration area and it's not
uh it's not mainline yet. Um, so it'll
be it'll be cool to see that come. The
agentic by default thread I think is
something that I've been thinking a lot
about recently which is like
historically
for me as a developer I've thought about
models just as this thing that gives me
tokens in and out and then there was
lots of scaffolding in the ecosystem to
allow me to build those models. I think
this it's it's becoming very clear to me
that the models are becoming more
systematic themselves, like they're
doing more and more. And I think the
reasoning step is this like really
interesting place in which a lot of
that's going to happen. And Jack's going
to talk about the scaling up of
reasoning. Um, but I do think it'll be
interesting to see like how much of the
scaffolding work that's happened in the
past ends up just like being a part of
that reasoning step and like what that
means for people who are building
products and stuff like that. So, um,
it'll be interesting to see. We'll also
have more small models soon, which I'm
excited about, and big models. People
want large models, which I know. Um, so
I'm excited about that. And then the
last one is continuing to push the
frontier on infinite context. I think
the current model paradigm doesn't work
for infinite context. I think it's just
like impossible to scale up. Attention
doesn't work that way. Um, so I think
there'll be some new innovations to
hopefully help let people continue to
scale up the amount of context that
they're bringing in.
Um and Tulsi is the person who drives
all of our model stuff. So if you if you
have stuff you want to talk about Gemini
models, uh you have ideas for things
that don't work well, uh she is the
person running the show on the Gemini
model product side
and then developer stuff. Um so we have
lots of things coming which I'm excited
about. Um I think I'll highlight maybe
three that I think people are super
excited about. Embeddings I think we
have which is you know feels like early
AI stuff but I think is still super
important. Embeddings power most
people's um applications using Rag. Uh
we have a Gemini embeddings model which
is state-of-the-art. So excited to be
rolling that out to developers more
broadly in the next couple of weeks. Um
the deep research API I'm super
interested in. There's so many
interesting products that are built
around um this sort of research task and
people love the consumer product. So,
we're finding ways to bring a bunch of
that together um into a like bespoke
deep research API uh which will be
awesome. And then V3 and Imagine 4 in
the API as well. So, hopefully we'll see
that uh very very very soon. Um and as
we work to scale and and make that
possible from a from a developer
platform side, I'll make one other quick
comment which is the um AI studio
product positioning which I also think
is interesting like AI studio just to to
be very clear is being built as a
developer platform. Um so we'll sort of
move away from this like kind of
consumerry feel and move much more
towards being a developer platform which
I'm personally very excited about
because I think that's what developers
want from us. Um, so it'll be awesome to
see that actually come to life with like
many new iterations of our of our
developer experience with agents built
in and hopefully things like jewels and
some of our developer coding agents um
natively in that experience which will
be which will be awesome to see. Um,
yeah, and that's that's what I have. I
appreciate all the people who send lots
of great feedback about Gemini stuff. So
we'll we'll keep pushing the rock up the
hill and um I'll be around. So if you
have more feedback, come find me and
we'll we'll keep making Gemini great for
everyone. So thanks and I appreciate it.
[Music]